[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen aus der steiermark
hier von einem geschichtsträchtigen ort
hier wurde 2009 10 im rahmen der
schneekatastrophe nachdem er zehn tage
in seiner hütte eingeschlossen war
der hüttenwirt der hochrhön bling hütte
von uns gerettet und ins tal geflogen
haben wie war das damals
ja danke oder das war sehr anstrengend
sei tag im schnee eingeschneit zu sein
ohne brennholz ohne wasser und die
wissen nicht ob die bundeswehr hat nur
durch derart vielen lieben dank das war
ein herausfordernder einsatz im rahmen
der schneekatastrophe 2009 10 aber nicht
einzige die große herausforderung für
die luftstreitkräfte während des starken
ereignisses 2009 10 war der einsatz von
insgesamt 19 hubschraubern in sieben
bundesländern
das jahr 2020 hat uns gezeigt dass diese
starke ereignisse immer mehr werden wir
waren ja jetzt anfang dezember schon
wieder in kärnten und in osttirol im
einsatz und heuer konnten wir durch die
nach beschaffung der leichten
mehrzweckhubschrauber und das update der
black hawks auch sicherstellen dass wir
in zukunft fit sind für die neuen
ereignisse
[Musik]